this is an 8 news now breaking news  alert  and we do start with breaking news at  noon if you're having a hard time right  now getting on netflix disney plus maybe  using venmo you're not alone there is a  server outage at amazon web services and  it's impacting thousands of users and  numerous websites which actually  includes ticketmaster the ticketmaster  plan to start selling tickets for  adele's residency at caesar's palace  today you can kind of see the top of the  seating chart there instead caesars and  ticketmaster put the sale on pause  because they're trying to figure things  out right now fans will get an email  with updated information but this is a  very widespread server issue at aws